non
[Musique]
l'incubation vise à accompagner des
porteurs de projets de startups combien
de jeunes startups
il y des êtres de tester éprouvé et
validé la proposition de valeur quel
modèle économique pour ensuite bâtir une
feuille de route ou un plan
développement pour ces startups
l'accélération elle vise à accompagner
des start up qui ont déjà du chiffre
d'affaires déjà des clients référence
qu'on appelle une traction de marché à
béret et l'objectif doit être de
d'accélérer en fait la croissance le
développement commercial
[Musique]
les objectifs pour moi de l'accélération
et de l'accompagnement vias qui cube
c'est d'être épaulé être épaulé sur
différents aspects du développement
d'entreprise
quand on est un entrepreneur comme moi
ont extrêmement engagée pour servir le
client mais on a vraiment le la tête
dans le guidon en permanence
[Musique]